et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir sabrina bonsoir
alors sabrina ou publié aux éditions
grasset un livre intitulé score ou vous
racontez vos années de prostitution
d'abord au cours d'expériences
occasional puis au sein de prestigieuses
agences d'escorting international des
années vous avez gravi volontairement
les échelons d'une vie remplie d'argent
de champagne et de cocaïne une vie dont
vous avez bien failli ne jamais vous
relevez vous nous raconter votre
histoire à 20 heures
sabrina re bonsoir vous n'êtes ni le 12
mai 1989 dans le 14e arrondissement de
paris votre mère sophie était assistante
maternelle votre père mohamed bagagistes
puis chauffeur de taxi quand vos parents
divorcent votre mère retourne vivre au
moment où elle avait grandi et là elle
emménage avec un dénommé loïc alors à
l'époque votre mère vous tient bien
serré on vous dit toute façon et pas
besoin de beaucoup insister parce que à
l'époque la sexualité ne vous préoccupe
pas beaucoup non pas du tout j'étais pas
du tout porté sur le sexe
quand votre mère et loïc se séparer que
votre mère se met avec david là ça se
complique les 17 ans vous êtes en pleine
crise d'adolescence et vous abandonnez
votre scolarité pour un bep vente et
puis comme votre mère au même âge vous
monter à paris pour fuir le mans en fait
il y avait problème d'avoir connu paris
donc comment je m'ennuie ouais alors
c'est à l'âge de 18 ans que vous faites
l'amour pour la première fois et vous
dites je ne ressens pas grand chose non
je pensais que c'était un peu plus fun
en fait ouais j'ai été assez déçu
c'était moi le problème ça ça m'amusait
pas ouais
c'est là que votre mère meurt d'un
cancer des ovaires pour vous le choc est
terrible
oui c'était un peu mon pilier valastro
toujours posé sur ma maman et c'était
trop tôt
alors là vous multipliez les soirées
pour oublier tout ça et c'est comme ça
que vous rencontrez une dénommée livia
qui à 19 ans c'est à dire le manage que
vous qui est étudiante en lettres à la
fac de tolbiac lé jour et qui la nuit
vend ses charmes
j'étais assez émerveillé par cette fille
à moitié femme qui avait l'alluré d'une
princesse qui avait manqué de rien voilà
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas choqué
quand elle vous raconte ce qu'elle fait
non je vais m'énerver encore plus j'ai
envie aussi moi j'ai envie d'essayer il
a envie d' aventure tout à fait alors le
premier client c'est un plan à trois
avec livia et vous dites je n'ai pas
peur je n'ai pas honte vous êtes même
sexuellement excité et désireuse de voir
comment ça va se passer quoi oui c'est
comme si j'allais à un roman le
professionnel - puis je sais qu'elle est
avec moi je sais mais s'y connaît je me
sens pas seule alors vous dites le
client de me dégoûte pas plus qu'il ne
me plait il est juste un client
le premier client de ma vie d'escort oui
j'arrive à faire la part des choses tout
de suite ça se passe plutôt bien ensuite
vous dites j'ai l'impression de m'être
éclaté c'est trop bien je veux le
refaire non vous n'avez aucune
culpabilité non il n'y a pas un moment
où je me pose des questions si à partir
de ce moment-là que j'ai occulté tout ce
qui m'arrive à moi alors commencé à
travailler comme escort donc avec des
tarifs de 250 à 300 euros le plus
étonnant en fait dans notre histoire
c'est que vous ne trouviez pas
insupportable de vous retrouver nue sous
des rouges oki and des excités qui
transpire j'ai plus de pudeur ouais j'ai
plus aucun problème avec le corps des
autres aignan ensuite vous travaillez à
bruxelles dans un salon de massage qui
est en fait une maison close mais là bas
c'est autorisé et ladite vous vous
trouvez une sorte d'équilibré dit j'aime
ce que je fais ça peut paraître bizarre
mais je m'épanouis la sexualité ne me
fait pas peur j'aime séduire et j'aime
l'argent
pendant ces presque trois ans que j'ai
passés à être escorte c'est le seul
moment où je me sens si je me suis
sentie de mieux on était huit filles on
était une famille c'était comme mes
soeurs une belle unité c'est ce que je
recherchais je me sentais seul à ce
moment là en même temps vous dites
j'aime l'argent mais la patronne de ce
salon on prend quand même 40 %
alors c'est bien normal c'est aussi elle
nous aide à nous aux épaules et elle
nous aide à travailler donc à partir de
ce moment là ça devient normal qu'elle
et ses 40% elle le mérite pour nous
reste moment la main et le reste vous
vous le dépenser sans compter un petit
peu comme si cet argent vous brûler les
doigts voilà je décide de consumer de
consumer ma vie moi cet argent n'a pas
de sens et n'a pas de valeur alors votre
famille se doute de rien époque un non
pas du tout j'étais que je suis fille au
pair en belgique à ce moment là aucune
suspicion
alors vous voulez faire mieux parce que
ce qui est incroyable dans notre
histoire c'est que vous voulez gravir
des échelons et vous partez à genève ans
là bas aussi c'est assez courant s'est
institutionnalisée vous faites
enregistrer commissariat le type vous
dit est ce que vous faites ça de votre
plein gré oui bien sûr il pourquoi vous
faites ça da pour de l'argent voilà
alors ils essayent de vous mettre en
garde mais en fait il ne vous interdit
rien le flic non en fait même pour lui
tous assez banal on était une salle
d'attenté on était difficile de chaque
milieu différent non c'était juste ma
jeunesse qui le gênait je pense à ce
moment là alors au début vous travaillez
en appartement 700 euros par client vous
fait trois quatre clients par jour
aimez vous voulez quand même être
escorté travail en appartement ça vous
plaît pas j'ai un peu juste trop tous
ces films de défi des scores pour moi
c'était moins de sexe travaillait plus
se promener voir des belles choses
j'avais envie de sortir de cet
appartement
alors le premier boulot comme escort
donc ca me gêne chez un riche américain
et il vous donne mille 700 euros ce
tarif là c'est normal c'est les a là ce
qu'on apprend en lisant votre livre
c'est qu'en fait il ya des clients qui
veulent en fait plus que ça ils veulent
ce qu'on appelle la girlfriend
experience c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
non seulement vous coucher avec eux mais
vous viviez avec eux ils veulent qu'on
se comporte comme leur petit ami qu'on
fasse tout pareil présentent à leurs
familles alors ouais alors amis ont dit
non fait tout pareil le premier que vous
trouvez avec qui vous avez une
girlfriend experience lui veut vous
sortir de là et j'en ai pas envie parce
que pour moi à ce moment-là je suis
libre et de
devenir la propriété d'un homme - eh ben
ça mais tout alors toujours à genève
vous entrez dans une agence avait le
prestige qui est une agence très très
connue très classe un peu comme élite
pour les mannequins
on finissait par gagner quinze mille
euros par mois voyagez beaucoup vous
vivez comme une star alors votre journée
type c'est cool hein vous lever à midi
voilà c'est assez futile à manger chez
le coiffeur je faire des emplettes prié
le boulot entre 20h et 23h et puis une
fois que vous avez fini de bosser je
vais boire du champagne et copines voilà
on va dépenser notre argent voilà on va
s'amuser on vaut bien une journée pour
mieux repartir au mieux du champagne de
la vodka ou fumé des joints et vous
commencez à prendre de la coke oui on en
met partout j'en ai sous le nez à
longueur de journée
pendant un moment j'ai me dire que je
vais payet touché parce que un c'est
encore trop sauf que il est trop tard et
et j'ai envie d'essayer et là un jour
vous participez un documentaire sur la
prostitution qui est réalisé par
mireille darc pour france 3 alors on
vous dit votre visage ne sera pas filmer
donc vous acceptez de faire ce
documentaire pour mireille darc mais
vous avez un grain de beauté là qui vous
rend reconnaissable pour les gens qui
vous connaissent en tous les cas pour
moi c'était impossible après
inconsciemment c'est ce que cherchait
c'était qu'on me reconnaisse et oui
toute la terre va mater marconi à partir
de là vos copines vous bien même unité
était une sale [ __ ] quoi ben ça c'est la
base ouais votre père vous appelle pas
non vous savez vous qu'il appelait ça me
gêne ouais j'aurais aimé qu'ils me
contactent même cédé pour me reprocher
des tas de choses j'aurais même préféré
qu'ils m'insultent qui donne au moins un
signe à ce moment là on l'appelait vous
allez le voir et il vous dit si c'est
moi qui tu avais élevé ça serait pas
passé comme ça bon c'est qu'il a raison
non je pense que c'est un conte à ce
moment là ouais je pense que c'est un
peu facile de dire ça maintenant 1 quand
ma mère n'est plus là et que la
situation - un peu dans un gouffre en
fait alors vous continuez votre job
d'escort girls vous prenez de plus en
plus de cocaïne au début pas tous les
jours puis après tout les jours et un
jour vous retrouvé aux urgences
oui trop d'abus ouais je me rendais pas
compte et là vous avez gagné beaucoup de
blé niveau s 4000 euros ça prouve bien
qu'on est dans une société de
consommation et que tout cet argent
n'avait aucun sens j'aurais jamais et
enfin j'aurais jamais imaginé avoir une
maison à acheter une maison vous n'avez
pas thésauriser
à vous décider d'arrêter
à ce moment là et vous partez vous
installer à montpellier avec samuel et
vous bossez donc comme réceptionniste
dans un hôtel
pour 1400 euros par mois c'est à dire 2
presta comme on dit à genève mais oui un
peu moins punis au début ça fait bizarre
ça pique un peu on s'y habitue parce que
j'ai plus de plaisir à gagner cet argent
que que l'autre argent j'ai pu gagner
c'était à refaire je le ferai pas
j'ai connu peu de filles qu'ils aient ça
vraiment par des yeux mais pour l'argent
majorité josiane moi je trouve ça très
courageux vous venir est très courageux
d'avoir recommencé à rôder parce que
c'est très dur d'un seul coup de passer
à 1400 euros par mois c'est ce que vous
dites c'est presque tout ce qui a été le
plus dur pour vous c'est pas d'arrêter
la coke c'est d'arrêter l'argent oui
parce que j'ai je me suis habitué
et après vous êtes tombé amoureux choisi
la main et le fait de tomber amoureux ça
vous aider à vous en sortir certainement
sam à des tâches élargi ce soir mais non
seulement elle est tombée amoureuse mais
tomba amoureuse d'un handicapé oui d'un
athlète handisport
le hasard
[Applaudissements]
qui fait force et ses amis là j'étais
dans le métro il n'ya pas longtemps et
j'ai entendu des gamines derrière moi
dire ouais chez michto et la fille en
fait alors à les écouter j'ai compris
qu'en gros je vais dire clairement elle
fut c'est pour un ipod en gros c'est ça
est ce à dire que maintenant là toute
une génération de gamine qui en je sais
pas si elles sont conscients de 6
centimes culpabilité parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on s'en sorte mais ce
sens on est dans une jeune et je me dise
arrête un modèle ils n'en savent rien
problème voilà justement dans mon livre
c'est ce que j'explique je mens pas je
suis assez clair j'explique que je
l'aurais pas fait sinon j'ai su que les
conditions je suis capable de dire quand
j'étais malheureuse quand j'ai souffert
mais à côté de ça je suis surtout là
aussi pour montrer à quel point c'est
facile malheureusement dû tomber merci
de votre témoignage sur tous les plans
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu